i'm stuart varney i'm harris faulkner
i'm brian kilmeade and this
is the fox news rundown
friday june 11th 2021 i'm jessica
rosenthal
ahead of the g7 summit president biden
said one of his goals was to send russia
and china
a message and while he's overseas
senators from both parties agreed on
legislation
meant to make us more competitive what i
think the
the chinese communist party most
dislikes about this legislation
is that the u.s is starting to take
seriously the notion that we need to
invest in ourselves
we speak with indiana republican senator
todd young
i'm lisa brady the white house says the
president wants to look russia's leader
in the eye
but he has faced some criticism for the
upcoming meeting with vladimir putin
american presidents talked to russian
leaders during the height of the cold
war
and nobody thought anything of that you
know you've got to talk to your
friends you got to talk to your enemies
we speak with fox news sunday host chris
wallace
and i'm joe koncha i've got the final
word on the fox news rundown
[Music]
for the first time as president joe
biden is overseas meeting with the
leaders of several countries in the uk
for the
g7 summit and before he left he told
reporters
sentencing the alliance make it clear to
putin and to
china that europe and the united states
are tight
and the g7 is going to move thursday the
president pledged to donate
500 million pfizer made covet vaccines
through the global kovacs alliance to
more than 90
lower income countries we're going to
help lead the world out of this pandemic
working alongside our global partners
under the uk chairmanship of the g7
democracies of the world are posed to
deliver as well
president biden has said multiple times
in the context of his infrastructure
proposal
or foreign policy or covid that the
fight between democracies and
autocracies is on
and that autocracies believe they will
win because democracies like ours
require consensus
agreement in our case that's
bipartisanship there is one area in
which democrats and republicans have
come together
and it's well in fighting autocracies
specifically china
this week the senate passed the u.s
innovation and competition act
also known as the endless frontier act
we'll see if the house agrees to it
but the vote was 68 in favor of it
senate minority leader mitch mcconnell
voted for it as well
i think president biden's message is
actually
accurate indiana republican senator todd
young was a co-sponsor of the
legislation
we democracies can indeed if we stay
unified
we can win the 21st century and ensure
that our way of life and our values
continue to be protected but
that's going to require us coming
together to pass
important pieces of legislation and to
collectively work to resist some of the
malign behavior some of the predatory
behavior of the chinese communist party
the chinese communist party has for a
number of years now
been involved in economic predation
they've been stealing
our intellectual property they've been
dumping cheap goods into our markets
they have been requiring joint ownership
and companies that want to
sell into or operate in china so we
don't do any of these things
and when it comes to resisting this
we fail to come together it does send a
message to
the chinese communist party that maybe
we're not serious
as a country and as an alliance system
about resisting their predation so
that's why
it was really important this week for
the united states senate to come
together
and we saw a vote of over two-thirds of
the united states senate republicans and
democrats
to make sure that we boldly invest in
what is
candidly the most sweeping broad-based
anti-chinese communist party legislation
in our nation's history
and uh the real point of emphasis on
this legislation is is making sure that
when it comes to technology development
the us leads the way so that we might
outgrow
odd innovate and out compete the chinese
communist party
yeah let's talk a little bit about what
is in this bill and just to be clear
you were a part of the endless frontier
act that is within the u.s innovation
and competition act that got passed
that's the name of the bill
talk to me about what is in this what
are we spending money on here and effort
on here
so we are investing in some critical
21st
century cutting edge technologies
many of which have direct military
applications all of which
will be required to ensure that our
workers are the most productive in the
world
and therefore we remain among the most
prosperous countries in the world
we're really taking a page right out of
our post
world war ii years where we invested in
our national
scientific enterprise we invested
through our universities international
laboratories
in things like aerospace and and
medical equipment we developed an entire
aerospace industry we came up with
breakthroughs like
mris and and uh on account of these
breakthrough technologies we're able to
spin off
businesses and and uh even develop
entirely new sectors of our
uh economy that wealth
and that bringing to bear of the
american
creative and innovative and
entrepreneurial spirit
helped us defeat the soviet union we
need to
essentially adopt the same model as we
relate to the chinese communist party
we'll continue to
do some business with the chinese they
have a different
form of government and a different
sort of economy than the soviet union
had
but what is for certain is that when it
comes to these key tech areas
and more broadly our economic growth we
need to work with our our partners and
allies around the world and ensure that
we're not out matched or outpaced at any
moment
by the chinese the chinese did not like
this act that passed their foreign
affairs committee said that this bill
seeks to exaggerate and spread
the so-called china threat to maintain
global american hegemony
using human rights and religion as
excuses to interfere in china's domestic
politics
and deprive china of its legitimate
development rights
i'm wondering what exactly they're
afraid of in this legislation
and i'm going to list off some things
here is it the part of the legislation
that says
taiwanese officials can wear their
uniforms and fly their flag here when
they're on official business
is it the part that says intelligence
reports need to be gathered on chinese
objectives
in international organizations or is it
the part that says we will be doing
extra work with our allies in an effort
to compete with them
these are some of the things that are in
this legislation and i'm wondering what
is your read
on what the chinese read is of the
legislation
well there's not much to like if you're
xi jinping
in this anti-chinese communist party
legislation uh so between xi jinping and
and bernie sanders i know there's been
some uh shall we say principled
opposition to uh these uh key strategic
investments what i think the the chinese
communist party
most dislikes about this legislation
is that the u.s is starting to take
seriously the notion that we need to
invest in ourselves
in our people through training and
education and
opportunities for all of our our
citizens regardless of where they live
and and what circumstances they grew up
in and in our key technology areas
so that we can start the businesses
that will help define the 21st century
and
ensure that people in my state of
indiana and
across the heartland can enjoy 21st
century
high paying jobs and giving us the
wherewithal
to hopefully deter any conflict with the
chinese and
and resist any pressure they might place
on some of their neighbors
but should any uh conflict ever arise uh
we will be uh ensuring that our war
fighters never have to fight a fair
fight if we have the most sophisticated
technology
senator do we need to walk some line
here you know
the chinese owned quite a bit of our
debt right they make a lot of our
critical supplies our pharmaceuticals
we're talking about bringing supply
chains back here what kind of line do we
need to walk do we need to be
hesitant about upsetting them
at all and i don't mean that like oh we
should bow to the chinese but
they could disrupt us right i mean we do
make a lot of things over there still
well and we will continue to make a lot
of things over there
one would hope if we make the right sort
of investments
that the things that require the
greatest level
of skill to make
and therefore compensate our workers the
most for making
those are made here in the united states
we want to import
cheap things out of asia and other
countries comparatively so
our country can benefit from trade if we
do trade right
and if we engage in fair trade and if we
ensure that we have mechanisms
to train people and support people if
trade
or automation disrupts their lives so
yes we have to be careful but i think
the best way we can be careful
is by ensuring uh that we don't uh
regard this competition
between the united states as china is is
exclusively
one between two countries but instead if
we play this right this is actually
going to be a competition between
china and the rest of the world i mean
who really wants to be
china's partner um really no one
they engage in predation even with their
so-called
partners uh they they engage in debt
trapped diplomacy
they bully their neighbors the only real
ally of sorts that they might have is
north korea and even with them they have
a conflicted
sort of tense relationship and
so the best china can hope for is to
uh uh is to recruit a bunch of vassal
states
by investing in them and scaring them
into their orbit
the best we can do is continue to live
up to our value system
and reassure our allies that we will
work with them to win the 21st century
that's interesting um recently wrestling
and movie star john cena apologized
pretty profusely for calling taiwan a
country he was extremely apologetic to
the chinese people and it reminded a lot
of us of the daryl mori tweet the
houston rockets gm
uh said that he stood with the people of
hong kong and the nba backed his freedom
of speech at that time the chinese then
canceled a bunch of scheduled nba events
and game airings on tv there
what do you make of this whole china has
on our entertainment and sports
industries because it's it's not
matching the language
we're now hearing out of the beltway or
even from our intelligence agencies
about china
well look it's to some extent
unfortunately reflective of the fact
that the leaders of many of our
institutions
many government leaders leaders of
higher education
certain members of the media members of
our philanthropic community
even organized religion have grown out
of touch
with the american people in fact many
of these leaders consider themselves
citizens of the world not really
citizens of
of the united states and part of this
nation so
um when when uh our elites
when many of our leaders and and those
who have benefited from
the laws and the culture and history
of this society you know see themselves
in that way
i think they're more inclined to bow to
the pressure for
financial purposes of the chinese
communist party
so what we really need to do is um
is to call out these episodes and
um let's let uh our business leaders uh
most especially and and members of
other institutions know that you know
earning a buck is important it's it's
part of what it means to be an american
we're a capitalist society
and it's great but standing on principle
and standing up for the american way as
opposed to
kowtowing to chinese dictators
is also very important and i don't think
it's very difficult to reconcile the two
in fact uh i i just dined with the
ambassador
from taiwan now uh it will upset xi
jinping and perhaps upset the
sensitivities of
of uh some people here in america
that i refer to the ambassador of taiwan
as the ambassador as opposed to the
representative
but this is about reassuring our
democratic allies around the world just
as the president has emphasized
if our government leaders can't do it
and the leaders of our other
institutions can't do it then the
american people will begin to lose
faith in our leaders indiana republican
senator todd young thank you so much for
your time
thank you
this is joe koncha with your fox news
commentary coming up
when president biden first landed in
england on wednesday
he wasted no time teeing up next week's
meeting
in geneva to meet with mr putin to let
him know
what i want him to know
that summit with russia's president will
be after the strong show of unity the
white house expects at the g7
and nato gatherings already reflected in
his first bilateral meeting
with british prime minister boris
johnson who called their discussion
thursday
a breath of fresh air reaffirming a
shared commitment between the two
nations to address many issues
from covet and climate to trade and
security even though the two leaders
have had personal and political
differences in the past
less than five months into the biden
presidency how important
is this trip well it's not make a break
but
uh what's the old line you don't never
get a second chance to make a first
impression
chris wallace is the host of fox news
sunday and i think he's got to make a
first impression both on his friends
our friends and our adversaries um
he's meeting with uh the g7 he's meeting
with
nato he's meeting with the european
union and i think he wants to say
uh i'm i'm a different president than uh
donald trump was i'm going to be more of
a uh of a supporter and an ally and a
friend
and less of a critic uh and that's
important
uh and particularly important in things
like trying to mobilize
uh the west against china uh on a
variety of issues
and then of course he's got the big
meeting in less than a week
with uh vladimir putin in geneva and
i think he wants to it's not going to be
any big agreement that comes out of this
but i do think he wants to
make it clear to putin his resolve
american resolve
you know right now i mean there are a
lot of issues the ukraine and
uh nuclear arms but i think the most
important and issue affecting americans
right now is ransomware
and the fact that these gangs of hackers
inside russia are shutting down our oil
pipelines are shutting down our meat
supply system
and he's somehow got to make it clear to
putin this can't go on
uh even if you're not formally in charge
of it you've got to shut it down or
you're going to pay a price
so i think it's an important meeting yes
that's
seems like maybe the biggest minefield
if you will of of the trip
right because he's he's had some critics
um i think from both sides of the aisle
among democrats anyway who said
you know maybe you shouldn't really be
giving him this meeting it amounts to a
reward for bad russian behavior yeah
yeah i mean he certainly has gotten that
criticism i think that's foolish i mean
i think that was a much more legitimate
um
statement to make about kim jong-un when
donald trump met with him
and you know raising the question of
whether you take this guy who's very
much on the sidelines who's
you know um kind of uh isolated and in a
box and you put them on the world stage
vladimir putin is the head of russia and
uh
and has been for what the better part of
20 years uh it's not like
you're elevating him he's he's he's
naturally elevated
simply by uh the nature of this position
and the length of his rule so i'm i'm
not sure that i agree with that and
look in terms of rewarding him
american presidents talk to uh russian
leaders during the height of the cold
war
uh and nobody thought anything of that
you know
you've got to talk to your friend
friends you got to talk to your enemies
on the subject of ransomware the fbi the
justice department are putting a lot
more
attention on it um are people going to
expect
the government to do more i mean the
white house has certainly made a point
of saying to the private sector look
you've got to step up
your cyber security game well i mean i
don't think that
that the federal government can do it
all by itself i'm not sure we want
the feds controlling the you know the
internet
the the online cyber uh infrastructure
of every private company in america i
think you'd get a lot of
of uh you know individual freedom civil
liberties people
having concerns about that the
government has got to do whatever it can
and i'm private companies
have to do what they can and individuals
i was uh online
just this week and uh got a pop-up and
you know because i'd gotten training
from fox didn't respond to it and yes it
turned out it was a
fishing ph uh fishing things and and i
knew
because i'd gotten the fox training
individuals need to know that so that
they don't
log on and suddenly their computer and
the computer system is taken over by
uh bad actors before the president's
trip
we had vice president kamala harris's
first foreign trip in this case
south of the border um she's been
getting
very mixed reviews from both sides is
that fair
yeah i think it is i think it was a bad
trip on her part
um it was her you know we talked about
you know get a second chance
to make a first impression uh she really
hasn't played a big role in the
international stage like
president biden has and here she is on
her first
trip foreign trip as vice president and
uh i think he made kind of a hash of it
you know if
if there's one thing you knew uh it was
that she was going to be asked i mean
this wasn't some
trick gotcha question why haven't you
gone to the border in the five months
you've been vice president
and when lester hold of nbc asked that
question she she gave a bad answer
when she said well i haven't been to
europe either
i i just think there were many better
ways she could have handled it than she
did
and i think she hurt herself i mean is
it fatal no
it wasn't a disaster but i think it was
a bad first
first a trip for her and a bad start to
her vice presidency
certainly the border is an issue that
the administration is going to
continue to get questions on and
continue
having to deal with infrastructure
seems to be an issue that's that's not
got no easy answer
either just before the president left
for his trip he pulled the plug on talks
with senator shelly moore capito the
lead
republican negotiator there are still
some bipartisan efforts on the hill
and at the white house which side comes
out looking worse though in a case like
this
when those direct talks uh that seem to
be making progress are ended
well you know like everything else i
think it ends up being very partisan if
you're a republican you don't like all
the spending you don't like the increase
in taxes
the president wants if you're a democrat
you think these
people don't care uh republicans and the
ones who were
pushing for these sharp limits on
spending and no taxes
uh that they don't care about the
average person my guess is
politically it probably plays to the
president's
advantage more because infrastructure is
popular and to the degree that he can
portray republicans
as blocking it i think that that works
to his benefit
but when the republicans say we're not
going to pay we're not going to raise
any taxes because that's just the red
line for republicans
as somebody said the other day asking
them to undo the trump tax cuts
is like asking democrats to repeal
obamacare it is just
a central uh
pillar of what they believe in and you
know to discredit that to go back
on that would really take off their base
remember
biden's pla original plan is still out
there four
trillion dollars in new government
spending and four trillion dollars of
new taxes
i don't think he'll get there but i
think in the end there'll be a
reconciliation bill
if it isn't if they don't pass anything
it'll be a real
uh mark against joe biden in the first
year of his presidency
simmering around the country um are a
number of school-related issues
especially
critical race theory we've had more and
more parents showing up at school board
meetings in loudoun county virginia in
particular
not just over that but the firing of a
gym teacher who spoke out against a
transgender related policy
a judge ended up ordering that that
teacher get his job back
it seems like many parents around the
country though have come out of the
pandemic
fired up on a variety of issues yeah i
think that's
that's probably true um you know they've
had a long time to think about it
they're not very favorably disposed
towards their school
system and particularly not to the
teachers unions because they would
love to have gotten their kids back a
lot sooner
and there are some social issues and
frankly republicans are pushing them
uh like critical race theory like
transgender
participation transgender girl
participation in girl sports
i think i think these are issues that
animate
a lot of people around the country i saw
some video from this the the uh school
board meeting
in loudoun county which is in virginia
just west of dc
and people were pretty fired up about it
so uh
you know look remember a few years ago
i'm trying to i think maybe it was 2012
common core and the whole idea of this
core curriculum
mandated by the federal government um
now the feds are not mandating critical
race theory
uh but you know any idea that local
school districts don't have
control over how
their kids are being taught is going to
set parents off there's just no question
about it
well there's so many things you could
talk about
who do you have this week on fox news
sunday well
uh the big story i think is the
president's trip we're going to be
talking to former secretary of state
mike pompeo get his view of how the
president's doing
at the midway point on sunday after he's
met with the allies before he meets
uh with putin we're also going to talk
to the democratic chair of the senate
foreign relations committee
robert menendez how he thinks it's going
and then on this question
of trans girl participation in sports
donna de verona
who back in the 60s was the golden girl
of american sport she won two gold
medals at the
64 olympics also in tokyo and she is
trying to find a middle way saying that
you know for
for post puberty that she doesn't think
that the trans girls can just
participate in girl sports that they
either have to have separate
competitions
or there needs to be some some hormone
treatment
to take away their uh their testosterone
advantages
pretty controversial interview uh with
her and i think it'll get a lot of
people talking
and that's all on fox news sunday not to
be missed chris wallace host of fox news
sunday
thank you so much for coming on the
rundown my pleasure thank you lisa
[Music]
i'm guy benson join me weekdays at 3 p.m
eastern as we break down
the biggest stories of the day with some
of the biggest newsmakers
and guests listen live on the fox news
app or get the free podcast
at guybensonshow.com rate and review the
fox news rundown on apple podcasts or
wherever you listen
and now some good news with tanya j
powers
a graduation speech given by a
massachusetts high school senior is one
that's sticking with many people
long after the notes of pomp and
circumstance have faded
verda tedda addressed her fellow seniors
at fitchburg high school and spoke about
resilience
the washington post reports verde's
family is from ghana and she not only is
headed to harvard
but she's been awarded a prestigious
state scholarship too
during the graduation ceremony she was
also given the school's highest honor
an award that came with forty thousand
dollars ten thousand dollars a year for
up to four years
she accepted it and headed back to her
seat but as another speech wrapped up
she went back up to the stage for an
unscripted moment that people nationwide
are talking about
verda said she'd been hearing the
addresses from school leaders who talked
about being bold and selfless
and she announced that she wanted the
school administrators to consider giving
her award money to someone going to a
community college
like the one that helped her mom who
went to community college when she was
39.
virta plans to study chemistry on a
pre-med track at harvard
and she later told the boston globe that
she had already gotten scholarships and
financial aid to help her go to college
fitchburg principal jeremy roche says
virta's wish for the award will be
honored
saying what she did quote represents the
best of humanity
tanya j powers fox news
[Music]
it's time for your fox news commentary
joe koncha
what's on your mind and what could only
be called a train wreck in a dumpster
fire vice president kamala harris really
stepped in it during an interview with
nbc's lester holt
do you have any plans to visit the
border at some point
you know we are going to the border
we've been to the border
so this whole this whole this whole
thing about the border we've been to the
border
we've been to the border you haven't
been to the border i
and i haven't been to europe and i mean
i don't well we could see why the white
house won't allow her to even sniff
anything resembling a press conference
since being appointed as borders are
nearly 80 days ago
because this is a politician who can't
handle basic questions
meanwhile things are only getting worse
at the catastrophe at the u.s southern
border a border the vp refuses to visit
save the tape any talk of kamala 2024
just ended following this disaster of a
trip to central america
i'm joe koncha
you've been listening to the fox news
rundown stay up to date by subscribing
to this podcast at foxnewspodcasts.com
and for up to the minute news go to
foxnews.com
[Music]
did you hear the news now you can with
instant updates from fox news for amazon
alexa
just say alexa play news from fox
in fox news it's the latest when you
need it
on demand from fox news and amazon alexa